what's going on guys this is rob and i
have a theory video for you guys today
which by the way you will hear more
voices on the channel besides mine it's
the only way to keep myself from burning
out and basically just quitting and
shutting down the channel because i'm
kind of going crazy just doing it all on
my own
so you are going to hear gordon aka red
muffler man you are going to hear quran
he's a guy that i don't think you've
heard yet but you may have but you'll
hear more of him on the channel but i
have a theory that avengers secret wars
is going to introduce galactus to the
mcu and i know a lot of people are kind
of like really you think galactus will
be introduced in avengers secret wars
yes yes i do and here's the reason why
so let's talk about secret wars for a
second right what is secret wars okay so
seeker wars has had different iterations
over the years in marvel comics there
was the original secret wars back in
1984 by jim shooter that's the most
famous one so like all the heroes are
put on one ship all the villains are put
on another ship the beyonder brings them
all together he assembles battle world
he puts them on the world and says
everybody fight to the death and whoever
wins will get their wildest wish right
their wildest dream will come true so
basically the beyonder was pedro from
napoleon dynamite now the thing about
this is the second secret wars was
released a couple years later and
literally the beyonder came to earth
because after the events of the original
secret wars the beyonder was curious
about earth so it came to earth it kind
of hung around for a little bit killed
death caught all kinds of problems
across the universe the molecule man and
beyonder fought and literally shook the
multiverse like quite literally
earthquakes across the multiverse is how
powerful these guys were let me tell you
something if they adapt the molecule man
owen reese from the comics to the mcu
scholar witch has nothing on that guy
not not anything on that guy he'll be
the most ridiculously overpowered just
disgusting character that you would have
ever seen there is a better than fair
chance though that if they adapt the
molecule man to the mcu you'll be wildly
underpowered because how do you bring a
guy into the mcu that can alter the
atomic structure of matter on the
multiversal level the guy is basically
god so the thing about this is that in
secret wars number three which was an
unofficial secret war story this
actually gave us the nature of molecule
man's powers at least as they existed at
the time that he was in effect one half
of a cosmic cube right like literally a
wishing box in marvel comics hence the
reason why he was so powerful the other
half was the beyonder himself so that's
why they were basically equal in power
if the beyonder wasn't a smidge more
powerful than molecule man and then you
go into secret wars 2015 by jonathan
hickman son-son son
god that story was so fantastic it
didn't really have very many
similarities to the old secret war
stories outside of like the molecule man
the beyonders different things like that
so similar characters but everything was
basically different right it was the
collapse of the multiverse and all that
kind of stuff but the important thing
about this is that looking at the
original secret wars from 1984 that
story was made so that marvel could
basically launch a series of toys with
mattel and they had to launch an event
around it to give people a reason to buy
those toys and so the reason why this
matters is because for us as the comic
book readers or at least not really me
at the time i was i was zero years old i
was literally being born when that story
came out
i was being born sometime during that
year but when that when that story
originally came out as comic book
readers people basically knew who those
characters were because it was the most
popular villains against the most
popular heroes for the average person
who had never read a comic once in their
life and only knew about characters in
passing they were just being suddenly
introduced to characters that they had
never seen or heard of before so sure
they knew of spider-man and like the
fantastic four probably captain america
most likely because i'm pretty sure he
was there and a few others but like that
was basically it it was just suddenly
galactus and they're like who the hell's
galactus and it's like this is galactus
that really tall guy there who's
basically ignoring everybody like it was
just kind of thrown on them all of a
sudden and i feel like that's what the
mcu would do with secret wars now they
can actually get away with this now i
know like super hardcore people who
think like everything needs to be
explained right like here's the origin
for this character and here's the origin
for that character and here's the origin
for this pencil that hawkeye's using in
this scene because everything needs an
origin because everything has to follow
continuity right for like the die hard
continuity fans they're probably gonna
get a little bit upset about this but
they're like a fraction of a fraction of
a fraction of a fraction of a percent of
the people who are watching these movies
so they don't really matter that much
but for the average person going in
there you could literally just throw
galactus and the silver surfer in and
the reason why is because we've seen the
silver surfer and the anticipation of
galactus has built up through a fever
pitch all the way to the point that like
most people know who he is even if only
by physical appearance but they don't
really know anything about him so
literally you could just have some scene
in the movie where by whatever manner
and whatever means things unfold and
then suddenly like galactus is there and
then somebody is the voice of the
audience the casual moviegoer who
doesn't know who galactus is and they're
like who's that person and then like
this silver surfer comes up which most
everybody knows who the silver surfer is
even if they don't know the nuance of
the relationship between the silver
surfer and galactus they're aware that
the silver surfer is essentially a
herald of galactus and if they're not
the movie will take care of it for them
right but literally the silver surfer is
like that's galactus he consumes worlds
if that moment happens in the movie
comic book fans are gonna freak the
average movie person is gonna get
excited too even though they don't know
why and then once the movie's over
videos like mine are going to turn them
into experts over comics explain so it's
going to be one of those cool little
moments right but they could definitely
do that right because people are aware
of the concept of galactus they're aware
of the concept of silver surfer seeing
different characters like that suddenly
appear in the movie honestly it's
probably the best place to do it because
outside of the fantastic four film which
the rumors are out there and i wouldn't
give them a whole lot of credibility
it's literally like somebody on
twitter's like i heard from a guy who
heard from a guy who heard from a guy
who got coffee for a producer at marvel
studios that the beyonder is going to
have a major role in the fantastic four
so like you know ticket for what it's
worth but outside of the fantastic four
movie i don't really see where or how
they would introduce galactus into the
mcu the only way to really do it is in
like guardians of the galaxy three and
he's just kind of mentioned by name
right in the same way that like thanos
was mentioned in the first guardians
movie where they just kind of referred
to him as a manta a mad titan and we
were all kind of disappointed because we
were all kind of hoping that like the
nova corps would would treat him like
voldemort right like he who must not be
named like thanos just instills fear in
everybody right like if they're like and
thanos the mad titan and i was like i
mean it could have been a little more
than that you know i mean it could have
been a little you know a little fear
going on there you know a little
something a little emotional reaction
not just kind of skimming over it but
nonetheless right it could be something
like that right where it's just like you
know this happened or that happened or
there's some kind of conversation that
goes on and then somebody's like
galactus is on the move again and and or
it's like people who are just like the
the guardians are at like some like
nowhere or something like that there's
this huge influx of refugees and people
are like where are all these refugees
coming from and it's like galactus just
consumed their world dunzo right that's
all you get it's just like one single
thing like that and it's like galactus
exists yes like a reference to that guy
and that's all you would really need at
the very least to kind of get the ball
rolling for the introduction of his
character but i think in all honesty
secret wars is a great place to
introduce him it's a great way to bring
him in right to just say like yep he
exists out there and we've kind of
alluded to him and we teased him a
little bit this is your first real
chance to get to see him right we don't
need like some movie that gives us like
a full on origin of galactus that's one
of the things to know the origin of
galactus and marvel comics didn't happen
until some 20 years after he was
originally released right after he was
originally given to us in the old coming
of galactus stories in the what was it
fantastic 4 44 through 46 i think or
something like that 46-48 it was in the
40s it was in the the issue 40s right
like somewhere between 41 and 49 but
like between those the introduction
there and the thor comics by walt
simonsen we never got an origin there so
it took a while for us to get one so we
don't need like a full-on origin of the
character in the mcu we just kind of
need to see them and i think secret wars
is the best place to introduce them the
real question you have to ask here is if
they go that route are they going to do
that for other characters or are they
going to do that for other groups would
it be something like the dire race or
the introduction of the shiar or
something along those lines now in that
instance if they did that they would
likely be characters that you see and
they exist there but they really they
might not give them a whole lot of of
exposition because even
reasonable comic book fans aren't
necessarily sure or aren't really that
that familiar with the dire race or the
shia empire they're aware of them but in
terms of like the intricacies of the
group the average comic book reader
probably doesn't know too much about
them so the average moviegoer is going
to be clueless about those guys so i
don't know if they necessarily do
something like that but there's a lot of
potential there for the introduction of
teams that we wouldn't normally see
groups that we wouldn't normally see or
individuals we wouldn't normally see
right to just kind of throw them into
secret wars say like hey they're there
and then just kind of call it a day if
they wanted to introduce like phyla vel
quasar or something along those lines
that's the benefit to doing a story like
secret wars is that it can one give us
variance of characters that we know from
across the multiverse or two it can give
us characters that we've never seen
before that exist in the universe and
kind of give us this ongoing background
theme that's really been happening since
the first guardians film by james gunn
which is the universe is a massive place
and there's a lot of stuff that we don't
know right like a lot of people ask that
question like if galactics exists in the
mcu how come we haven't seen him by now
well the universe is really big like
really
really really big right it's
pretty sizable and it's not unreasonable
to believe that galactus is just over
there on the other side of the universe
and we just haven't seen him yet because
he's just been hanging out there because
the eaton's good i don't know right it's
the best buffet in town like what reason
would he have to leave like it's just
entirely possible that that's the case
right so again i think there's some
great possibilities here for things that
we can see in the marvel cinematic
universe in secret wars i'm a little
more on on in favor of the idea of
introducing galactus in fantastic four
outside of the november release date i
don't think we really have anything for
that film i don't think we have like any
villains lined up i don't think that
they really even have a plot formed i
think it's just kind of like the movie's
coming out then and we're gonna start
working on it here in the next couple
months or so and like that's basically
it right so we've got a little while so
i'm kind of curious to see how it all
unfolds i mean a lot of time is going to
pass between now and avengers secret
wars so there's going to be a lot of
things that they can do and they already
had their big 10-year meeting right so
like how things are going to look for
the next 10 years so they've already got
it mapped out so there's a lot of stuff
that was not not talked about in san
diego that's going to be talked about at
d23 so we might have to kind of wait
till d23 comes out to see how all you
know whether this theory might be
credible or something like that like
they literally could come out with a tv
show called marvel studios
galactus and it's just about him and
that's it i have no idea right like
galactus and friends which honestly i
would kind of watch that show if it was
a show called galactus and friends and
he's just like traveling around the
cosmos consuming worlds but it's like a
buddy cop film between himself and like
reed richards of the fantastic four with
the ultimate nullifier those you guys
don't know what that is doesn't matter
but like a buddy cop type movie or type
tv show i'd watch the hell out of that
but regardless i'm rambling time to end
this let me know what you guys think
down in the comments section
thank you all for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace